well let's talk to the education
secretary gavin williamson good to see
you this morning look 1.4 billion pounds
you're putting into this it sounds like
a lot of money
on the offset but you're not spending
the money that the experts say you
should
why not well it is a lot of money and it
builds on 1.7 billion pounds that we've
already committed
in terms of actually delivering for
children is an extra 100 million hours
of tutoring for children
is making sure that uh that children who
need that help that need that support
we're delivering that tutoring
revolution
to help them get it but we recognize
that it's part of a process as we've
as i just said over the last 12 months
we've already announced
a previous 1.7 billion pounds worth of
additional funding
and we're looking at a whole raft of
additional ideas
of how we can continue support our
children
making sure none of them are left behind
yeah but i mean you you had
you appointed a catch-up tsar and that
catch-up czar says
you need 15 billion pounds
well what we've been doing is working
very closely with uh
sir kevin collins and actually the
interventions around
tutoring uh the interventions about
driving up teacher quality
these are very much built on the work
that we've been doing together
recognizing how incredibly important it
is
that we take on these interventions in
order to be able to help children
that's what we're doing you know for so
long we've known that
tutoring is a real benefit for children
but sadly it's often been for preserve
of
those who have that little bit more
wealthy
what we're doing is we're expanding it
out so children
right across the country are able to
benefit up to
six million children benefiting from
this tutoring regime
but also making it simpler and easier
for schools to be able to
access and to use this is going to
deliver
such a revolution in terms of teaching
and
having gone to schools and spoken to
children who are already benefiting from
it
they're seeing the difference children
are seeing the difference
parents are seeing the difference and i
believe teachers are also seeing the
difference that's why
it's right we continue to build on that
success but
sir kevin collins says more will be
needed to meet the scale of the
challenge he's effectively saying in
that
you haven't done enough
and what we all recognize and what i
would say is we
do forgive me is it is it to be done
is is he right would you have liked to
have put more money into this if you
had free reign to do so
what i was just saying is that we
recognize that this is part of a process
uh
just a few months ago just three months
ago we were announcing an extra
700 million pounds worth of catch up to
support children
not just over the summer period but
going into the next year
just a few months before that we're
announcing a further 1 billion pounds
and this is very much part of a process
continuing to build on the success
of the initiatives that are already
working in schools
we're making sure that we build on them
we expand them
so that more children are able to
benefit so yes we're very much looking
as to
how we can continue to build on that
yeah forgive me but but
how is this part of a process because
the the children involved here
i mean depending on where they are
within the the the academic
process but a lot of them don't have
time for this to be built up this needs
to be dealt with immediately for
those older children in particular
well that's why we've taken the measures
we have done today of announcing
uh 1.4 billion pounds extra recognizing
their interventions that we want to see
put in place straight into the next
academic year
that's why we announced the previous 1.7
billion pounds because we recognized
we wanted to get schools moving forward
on this
longer term we do though want to see
further changes and further improvements
that's why we're doing a review in terms
of
time within schools how best we can use
it
i think there's a good a debate to be
had as to
whether children should be exiting the
school gated
as they do in some schools at 2 45 or
whether they should be
in school later have we condensed down
the
have we condensed down the lunch time
used to be an hour sometimes in schools
it's half an hour
it's right that we work with schools and
teachers
as well as parents and children as to
what delivers them the best benefits
but you're right there are some children
in their academic career there's a
coming
close to the end of their academic life
that's why we're offering the
option of a repeat year so those
children who don't think that they've
been able to get the very best out
of their education as a result of a
pandemic are able to repeat it
these are actions recognizing the fact
that there is an urgency there
and that's why we committed over three
billion pounds worth of investment
to supporting children with a
recognition that more
needs to be done but i mean you
appointed
sir sir kevin collins as the catch-up
czar i mean
do you trust him do you agree with him
so so we've been working incredibly
closely at all stages
that's that's a very straightforward
question do you trust him
do you believe in what he's trying to
achieve
yes or no absolutely and these are why
the interventions
this is
he says you need 15 billion pounds
you've given him 1.4 in this 1.7 earlier
on as you say
but he says you need 15 billion if you
trust him if you
absolutely agree with him why isn't he
getting that money
so what we've been doing is working with
sir kevin on a whole package of measures
one of those is the expansion of our
tutoring program
there's a billion pounds going into that
the other key element of
that expansion and sort of support for
schools and children
is actually through teacher quality as
well that's why we're committing
400 million pounds to early years and
driving up teacher quality
because actually these are interventions
that we've worked on together
and actually this is why we're
organizing a review in terms of time
in terms of how we look at expanding
time
what is best for schools but most
importantly
what's best for pupils what are the best
interventions where there's the most
evidence that goes to show this is going
to have the biggest
impact on children and what we're
delivering is
forgive me forgive me look i i hate
shouty
argumentative interviews i really do but
it would be really helpful if you could
answer the question
which is if he says he you know to
implement what needs to be implemented
you need
15 billion pounds why is that money not
coming forward
did you fight for that money have you
been told you can't have that money
what's going on
what we're doing is we're building up a
whole set of interventions
including the 1.7 billion pounds that's
already been committed
complemented by 1.4 billion pounds these
are all measures that are going to have
a direct
impact on children they're going to have
a direct impact in terms of actually the
amount of tutoring children are going to
be able to get
this is far too long been for preserve
of those who have
been the wealthiest and only been able
to afford it
we're making sure that that's expanded
so all children are able to benefit
but we recognize there's more work to be
done this is part of a process and this
is why we're launching for review
in terms of how we can best support
children in terms of
their schooling and one of those
elements is about time
is there extra time that is required for
children to be able to
be able to be in the classroom not just
for study
but also for enrichment activity as well
and that's
what we're undertaking to do but if
that's so important why hasn't that
happened an extra half hour on the
school day was what was being
sort of touted yesterday that hasn't
come about
i mean that would be at least something
which was a universal approach which did
affect all children why has that not
happened you wanted that didn't you
so what we've recognized is that we want
to bring forward the interventions that
we can deliver
most rapidly for most children and
ensure that actually
we're able to have this hitting the road
as quickly as possible
we've already started the expansion of
the tutoring regime
they're aiming to get quarter of a
million children signed up to it
but we want to take that further that
was one of those things and one of those
measures that we're able to
implement and start delivering from
september
and it's important that we continue to
do that on the
teacher development we are expanding our
daily career frameworks so those
teachers i'm i'm sorry i'm sorry to
interrupt
but you you've mentioned tutoring a few
times brought about in september
getting that implemented only a few
weeks ago nick gibb the school's
minister
said that the number of children
currently getting tutoring was one
percent of pupils
and this is part of a reason as to why
we're expanding our sort of tutoring
program
we're on course to have signed up by the
end of this year
quarter of a million pupils but what
we're recognizing is we want to do more
we want to take that to more pupils we
want to see up to six million
children across our school system be
able to benefit from that and be able to
be
in the classroom benefiting from small
group group tutoring
we're seeing uh you know the evidence
goes to show
that this delivers real help to children
it goes and sort of
helps them catch up in the learning
they've lost so
children who have maybe found themselves
falling up to two months behind as a
result of a pandemic
as a result of these sessions can catch
up to between either
three and five months of lost
you say the six million pupils been
affected by all of this
you're hoping to step up the tutoring to
250
000 i mean that in itself is a drop in
the ocean
sorry you misheard me actually there
because there's 250 as part of the
current scheme that we're aiming to have
250
000 pupils signed up by the end of this
academic year
but what we're doing as a result of this
extra money is stepping that up
so it's going to be able to impact and
benefit up to six million pupils right
across
england that's the scale of expansion
of this program because it works it
delivers results for children
it is what actually not just children
are wanting but
parents are wanting as well because
they're seeing the results
and that's why we're expanding it so
massively uh
compared to where it's been at because
the evidence when you go into schools
when you talk to children who are
benefiting from this tutoring
you're hearing from them about how it's
helping them catch up on their maths
how is helping them better understand
their english
it's giving them that advantage in order
to be able to claw back that time
and that's why we've wanted to take it
away you know expand it from
not just a quarter of a million pupils
or so going to be benefiting it from
this year
but expand it massively next year so
that
millions more are going to be able to
benefit from it i mean
if you're passionate about the the
the need for children to to get this
time
back if you like to recoup the losses
that they've had over the past 16 months
how hard did you actually push at the
treasury
to get the money that you needed
well all the time you're in discussions
right across government
but what's great is that actually both
prime minister and the chancellor
and everyone is committed to making sure
that we take the actions that are needed
in order to be able to help children
benefit that's why we've
continuously brought forward multiple
packages of money you know over three
billion pounds that we're investing in
catch up we've already announced so far
yeah but we are but if everyone if
everyone's so committed
why why are you only announcing today
ten percent of the money that your own
catch-up
tsar says you should have been
announcing today
what we're announcing is a package of
money and
actions that are going to be able to
yeah but why is it only
when they're coming back to school in
the next sort of few weeks
i mean it's it's a it's a pretty
straight it's a pretty straight question
and i'm sorry to keep interrupting i
hate
interrupting it's only 10
of the money that sir kevin collins says
you should have been announcing today
so why is that
so the reason that we're announcing this
package of money because these are
measures that can be deliverable
in the next academic year the measures
that are going to be able to benefit all
children
that's why we announced for 700 million
pounds just
just a few months ago that's why we
announced a billion pounds
in the summer of last year because
they're measures that are able to have
an impact
on children immediately that's been our
focus of making sure that we deliver for
children
straight away that's what we're going to
continue to do and the tutoring
has the biggest single impact in terms
of children's attainment
what they're able to deliver children
want it parents want it
and actually we're delivering it on a
scale that's never been
seen before and it is a true revolution
in terms of what we're delivering for
our schools and
and you know a 1.4 billion pound package
you know is an important step in terms
of actually
ensuring children benefit in a very real
way
in terms of being able to pick up this
extra tutoring in the classroom
minister good to talk to you thank you